let's talk about old people in fact that
makes everybody happy we're dedicating
this segment Blanche Devereaux by the
way all people are getting more F TD's
then ever we've got proof between 2011
and 2012
FTI sexually transmitted infection
increased by 3 percent for those between
45 and 65
and seven percent for those over 60 when
it comes to forgetting about safe sex we
always think
love the vulnerability of young people
but there's the Fifty Shades of Grey
effect were older people are being more
explorative but not necessarily
remembering to use a condom that's from
doctor Jones is the chairwoman
about the British Medical Association's
GP committee
so yeah go that personal
the David pointed out that STI
has more politically correct that std's
who was making that argument
haa what the Ikea gonorrhea is always
been super uppity about that
gotten you know going to a beard things
about it these are what we call the
Wreckers wasn't what which one was the
clap
a guy with that area would you rather
have a disease or infection
right that's all that mattered lol I
Drive infection and disease I think I'd
rather
I think I'd rather have a disease and
infection can give you sepsis I'm I
I'm afraid of sepsis your fears that I
fare such as hell
I accept this is what it is infection
goes horribly Corrado
you know what FDA you don't die you need
to watch more house I'll
your result that at fault that the yeah
there yet all people having more sex and
then
look they worried the for the door easy
on the
old people order all rights are you
human 45 to 65
they still had SX yeah are you guys in
the
the 45 to you know when I get there
though and I
predicts liar what yet well now they
have by Agra too so I think that
probably has a lot to do with it breaks
in between by Agra and then what they're
calling the Fifty Shades of Grey effect
that
older people are being more sexually
expressive
yeah look assuming these aren't like
threatening conditions so lately about
obviously but I mean yeah 3 percent
increase in Tom in a7 percent increase
in others
might not be worth it I mean it might be
worth it do not use a condom
yeah like that like buying we are
leaving I don't expect the
week at all except that and at their
expert I figured that this was really a
polite way of saying look how many
people in their fifties are now having
anal sex
like but they didn't want to let things
without a belt to like who
you know better follow-up study that
they didn't put publish online
why do we get so weird about older
people and sex can work older people
alter 40
all I am worried but we think the people
having sex they're good people in their
twenties
pretty much a writer I gotta be another
I know there was a point appears that
the near
in your porn viewing yeah but your
younger bad Jimmy tired
basically the same generation there was
a moment
it happen on television and it happened
in sort of all
fantasy were all the sudden like the
women I was interested and we're all
38 years old yes just like that all of a
sudden it went from
I see a gorgeous 22-year-old and I think
she should be dressin Dale
a rather and now what some show when
there's a beautiful blonde 41-year-old
on television
Hat's nice bats really good at
I'm the same way they say that a lot how
who men are attracted to you has a lot
to do with how old her mother was when
they were young
so I was born late my mother's life so
I'm more attracted to women who may be
over 40 years old
for me to my mother's 42 in that is
literally the most depressing thing I've
heard ed
months you to make not only makes a
great for me because I'm married now
and I've been with my wife for fourteen
years and I'm more attracted to her now
than when we first started dating
I love working out for me know I'll or
gets depressing that you will get what
they get too if you wanna fuck your mom
are at the end of the day this is about
talking about it dollars's
it while I think about they say when
you're in bed though it's not just you
and your partners to you and your
partner to other people up for the
people
her parents and your parents are all in
bed together and that there are chemical
mingling
right to my I'm a loner what Israel you
are struck freudian
a min is it too late to teach older
people as or what we call them out on
people people people these people have a
higher
age it too late to teach them all the
same sex tricks because they didn't grow
up with that with
the sex ed we think that there in the
day the having sex with older person
it's like grain mill they stop to yell
get off my mock
you know I mean it's up the FedExCup
while on but that is wanna tell that
joke gag order as good
experts play yet I think that somebody
home in and get it but there are a lot
more of it
much at Latino I was using it in loooove
Balonne bad I go people I don't you yell
that you are yet you wanna piss off an
old person
walking along are part of our house not
it probably is
a little tougher to observe dry those
points on but again a bit we're not
seeing
about minimizing why cuz I am but a
couple that guy clomidia
you know like doing well that is what
penicillin step you completely by a
yeah I think the Cure with the
antibiotic what are we talking about
yeah if there are you guys having sex in
your seventies and eighties
I hope so I certainly hope so with each
other with yeah
that's where it's gonna go that route is
all leaving the federal today that we
need to because I don't think you do
experiment
the older I get I my desire for sex
it's just my ability right I'm tired I
get you know all that stuff gotta
boner pill what have you and so I think
I'll always want to have sex is just lay
a buddy just other things get there was
like the
my back here maybe if I stretched and
have a coffee you have a headache
right or I could just stay here and be
totally sedentary
like that all year at a very attractive
option